ces fameux la maia savez ce qui a
déclenché une polémique puisque elle a
posté sa sur instagram le jour de la
journée n'est pas de la femme et des
femmes c'est ça des droits des femmes
des droits des femmes regarder ce
qu'elle a postée alors est-ce qu'on peut
le voir ou pas en fait elle a posté un
petit à petit message un peu touchant
pour les gens voilà alors magali
qu'est-ce qu'elle a posté elle a posté
un texte à une belle photo avec un
parfum et danseurs elle a fait d'abord
un texte pour les femmes
voilà et c'était un placement de produit
pour ce parfum très bientôt quatre
heures de la journée de la femme est
derrière elle vous passez un petit
placement de produit sachant qu
effectivement toutes les femmes se sont
battues des années des années des années
voire un siècle pour que les femmes
soient libres aujourd'hui est un jour
voilà alors comprenez vous la polémique
pour eux ça de consensus qu'elle a
touché aussi beaucoup de 7 ou comprenez
vous la polémique à ya beaucoup de non
dits donc ça c'est étonnant à vauvert
voir mon goût matthieu ballet des quoi
tu me diras ce que tu en penses vraiment
que je comprends la polémique imaginez
que vous ayez un concert des restos du
coeur avec un des chanteurs qui a mis à
un grand truc et qu'une marque sur ses
vêtements ou toucherait de l'argent
vendre c'est complètement indécent on
peut pas vendre quelque chose le jour
d'une cause humanitaire surface est
complètement absurde notamment pour elle
pour les prochains placement produit
devra faire marrer à noter que ce que ce
que c'est la marque généralement qui
donne sa date de publication quand on
fait des postes pour s'enrôler pas
débuté sous contrat reste justement
magali alors l'enfant soeur est libre de
faire at il dit non la marque quand tu
sais toi mais quand on attend du cinéma
ne pas défiler mais je connais des
contrats des emplois nouveaux
gt2 protégeant mettons cumul je
reconnais losier a contraint un
influenceur c'est une personne qui est
libre de poster quand il a envie une
marque à droite demandé une date c'est
vrai mais en soi l'influencera droit de
dire non ma possession le messie et
assyriens mais donc un influenceur et
nuit brut devienne le mannequin les
filles est-ce que du coup elle a choisi
la date choisie la dette avec la marque
bien évidemment maintenant après moi
j'ai un truc à dire tout simple c'est
que les femmes elles sont battues pour
être libre tu dis quelque chose par
rapport à une association mais là c'est
pas une association déjà premièrement ça
n'a rien à voir avec des gens qui sont
dans la souffrance et c'est là on parle
d'une lutte ok très bien mais c'est pas
social tiff et deuxième temps en temps
il ya une femme qui souffre mais je peux
pas dire si elle a envie de poster ce
jour-là laisser la libre d'affaires en
croissance est battu pour la libye libre
le passé ils sont forts moi c'est un
travail c'est j'aime ça non mais quelle
at war est de travailler moi le jour de
l'assaut
le jour de l arrêtera dans ces cas là la
maison de travail et enfin la journée
s'est pas le droit de vendre ce qu'on
veut
parce qu'on n'est pas c'est pas ça pas
mal et tous ensemble jour devant la télé
c'est insupportable et il rêve déjà pas
beaucoup de monde à cause de l'info ne
perdez pas ceux qui restent
s'il vous plaît non mais s'est excusé
c'est pour la même qu'hier alors il
s'excuse elle dit c'est le courage et
son engagement à temps c'est pas ça ce
qu'elle a dit voilà les hauts et les bas
arrive à tout le monde parfois on se
sent démuni pour les maladresses
commises il faudra en prendre le recul
nécessaire pour se remettre en question
j'apprends et parfois offensif et des
erreurs bref je suis effectivement du
poste calamy mathieu en un mot toi
pourquoi tu étais ans et luc et moi même
avons été choqués pour le fait qu'elle
fait ça ce que je trouve très bien c'est
que des landes macho man à
l'intelligence et l'humilité de
reconnaître l'erreur est de dire leur
fait la plus choqué les femmes désirent
j'ai 25 ans j'apprends à les influencer
ce depuis un an l ap trompe pas attends
tu sais quoi je